[music playing]
- There's a bunch of packages
in here from the Netherlands.
So we're looking for narcotics.
Anywhere in Europe are pretty
good packages to check.
So here we have Great Britain.
This one looks good.
This is a package from the UK.
It's candy.
These are good.
OK, you've got a package
coming from the Netherlands,
says it has documents in it.
That looks like a CD case,
but inside, there's no CD.
It doesn't look right.
So we're going to take
a look at that one.
I don't see any
documents in here.
You're buying a video
game, it's not just
going to be blank like this.
And this is puffy.
There's red flags all over this.
Something interesting.
There's a rocky substance.
We see a lot of MDMA
from the Netherlands.
The person has put
cards inside, thanking
them for being a good customer.
They're not going
to get this order.
Now we're going to test
what we thought was MDMA.
I just need a little sample.
We don't need much.
Positive for MDMA ecstasy.
But this is a Schedule I,
so it's going to be seized.
And it'll be destroyed.